hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to oxygen not included
now I've made some progress we're pretty
much to the same place where we left off
but I made some changes and some
progress that we're gonna be focusing on
right now my biggest problem is that
we're running out of food and this whole
place is running out of oxygen so I
opened up this area to try to let some
things transfer through but in the end
there's another problem because we just
don't have nearly enough oxygen
production and then carbon dioxide is
just building up throughout here I'm
trying to build beds for them up here so
hopefully they're gonna have a little
less horrifying time and oh my god what
the [ __ ] just happened there okay then
that's gross oh boy let's bring another
person into this hellhole yeah why not
gastro phobia can't perform cook well
that's okay divers lungs that's what we
need people that can't breathe
we're gonna go with you Stacey come on
in here Stasia welcome to hell
alright so I've got a I'm just
continuing the plan like I would have
said that like I'm continuing but I did
deconstruct all this stuff here because
I obviously it wasn't necessary over
there this is going well over here I say
as olive vomits again just a good stress
response you know not too bad nothing
shabby about that one but so long as we
got this here we're gonna eventually
have algae delivery and I know that
they're gonna be able to get it because
it's right here and right here so when
they do get it they'll be able to put it
in these and hopefully keep these
running water is running low though we
are almost out of water here and I have
to have a system in place to get water
before we run out of water so that's my
next step for this one because if we
don't we're in trouble
this is broken again okay but least
those are going for those should be able
to do a good number on producing oxygen
and then the next step will be making
beds so that they have a good place to
sleep I'm gonna priority nine those oh
yeah yeah and then hopefully when we're
down here we can build a better
sanitation area with actual plumbing and
whatnot if that's possible I do not know
also I'm pretty sure slime when it's
converted into algae it produces
contaminated water so I mean while that
may not seem ideal what that does mean
is that it does produce water so that is
good so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
produce I'm gonna start the plans for
this I'm gonna build an air wire you
Snorri okay I'm gonna build an airlock
over there because I just kind of like
this as being you know a natural
separation but there is slime over here
so hopefully Gus the same thing every
time Gus the one thing you can't break
Gus
god damn it Gus whatever we're doing our
best here we're doing our best we're
doing our best we're all in this
together doing our best
it's kind of prioritized the connection
of that one all right all right you know
what I'm gonna build
I need to try to handle this stress
situation because all these people have
a lot of problems interrupted sleep new
friend stepped in contaminated water
grimy dirty hands so we need a lot of
things to try to fix that missing
resource bleach stone not kidding so
what we got to do is I'm gonna
prioritize this area here cuz it's gonna
be the sanitation area it just has to be
because otherwise [ __ ] we're not gonna
do anything
whoa what is with that what is with oh
my god oh whoa what is with all right
mop it up Oh
recycle it I guess goddamn hit the
battery you could just fix it you gotta
take a breather max my fave to continue
breaking your [ __ ] okay good
do bad boy that's a lot of vomiting
happening you're all gonna thank me when
this is over is tough love there's
learning through suffering that's a
thing that happens right that's a thing
that's a thing that parents do they make
their kids suffer and then they learn
that's how it works right I thought
that's how it works I think I think I'm
pretty sure that's always yeah pretty
sure okay so now we need to unleash the
slime really all I want to do is I want
to just dig out so that some slime is
exposed actually I don't even know if
they could reach that I'm just gonna dig
literally this just a tiny fraction whoa
actually prioritize the airlock first
and then do this okay there we go god
damn it we need algae holy [ __ ] we are
almost dead in the water for oxygen god
dammit
no algae Rick nope oxygen is done here
there's nothing in here this area is too
big to contain it all I guess we just I
don't really have enough algae
terrariums to be able to do this
I know algae terrariums are probably a
less intensive algae consumer and
probably these things are extremely
because they probably just burn the
algae while these things grow the algae
I just don't I'm just pretty sure that
these still would consume algae but
probably at a slower rate so what we got
to do I guess I just gotta focus on them
okay we're getting some algae out of
that hopefully no one falls to their
death please don't be too stupid and
fall to your death okay so those are
going that's good they just need water
and then they're good yeah that's the
thing that they consume they just
consume water so no matter what you're
running out of one resource or another
at least the slime
the slime is releasing maybe don't stay
in there what are you doing in there why
are you in there oh you can't get back
oh [ __ ] Oh No
are they stranded would it be easier to
build a ladder or would it be easier oh
my god we need to build a ladder that
would probably be the easiest way to get
out other than like tile what is what is
a tile need oh boy
okay so no I think a tile might be
easier because then you just need these
three tiles there cancel these
prioritize these I think these are less
material intensive too you go for that
everything else is lower priority I oh
my god I can't believe I just okay
alright then alright please let him get
out let him get out come on come on
there we go get out get out get out go
go go go go go okay I saved him I saved
you guys stop stop taking a breath and
just go
Noorie stop get out of there okay so the
all the oxygen terrariums are going
they're doing pretty good I guess I
could make [ __ ] someone's lashing out
again okay but you guys are gonna
survive and you're gonna thank me for
this I mean you're obviously not gonna
thank me for this but eventually you're
gonna thank me maybe
okay well oh one crisis cross that
solved infinite more to go oh boy so now
I really really really got to think
about water cuz if I don't everyone's
dead I know I keep saying that but
that's literally how this goes I gotta
get him water so I got a I got a figure
plumbing out so this plumbing works and
then the carbon dioxide scrubber is now
in the wrong place but it's whatever at
least it'll work so I gotta figure out
what it wants what does it want like
what do you want I don't get it like
this the liquid pump what does it want
empty pipe I don't get it Oh at least
everyone has a bed
everyone's dreaming of food
so they're probably starving you got to
figure out a way to get more food but
everyone keeps breaking everything
before I'm actually able to do anything
so what we're gonna do just for the sake
of stress relief we're gonna make these
massage tables just hey everybody you
want a massage come down to the algae
terrarium
and have yourself a lovely ol massage
also we're gonna build lamps you guys
like lamps right
I like lambs you like lamps I love lamp
all right everything in here and
tomorrow this is your priority make all
this [ __ ] and do that you can do that
all right good for you
all right so gas pump I don't know what
that's gonna do no wire connected of
course not why would there be oh they do
need wire why wouldn't they that's nice
okay and then connect that to this all
right do massage tables need anything
they don't seem to need power so
hopefully they can just blast out some
stress the duplicants are carrying a lot
of tension in there everything I'm aware
I'm aware he's breaking it as they're
running on it good job and then you [ __ ]
yourself great good to know you guys are
great you guys are awesome love you guys
to death okay this makes no sense I I'm
gonna obviously I'm doing something
wrong with this so I'm just gonna I'm
gonna just I'm gonna just figure this
out later
cuz obviously I'm doing something very
wrong and I don't want to do it until I
got it right at least we got massage
tables here so if anybody wants a
massage
hey Gus Lenny you want to side massage
table owner oh oh I get it
we've got an incredible food shortage an
outstandingly bad food shortage
starvation Oh who's starving Lenny
oh no Lenny this has been more stressed
I don't know why I no one's using their
massage tables
obviously don't you do that huh go for
it you wanna do that
all right so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna build just big beefy batteries so
hopefully if people actually do lash out
like maybe we can get some storage about
oh my god look at the light
well [ __ ] look at us we are flying by
it's so bright down there whoo oh yes
welcome another one to the fold when we
don't have enough food and this broken
max come on max damn it max of course
repair it and repair this too because
they're all broken
everyone's at max stress even even the
new person who's gonna be at absolute
max stress and stop it Dan stop it stop
it Dan okay fine whatever just do you
think okay I'm gonna build more microbe
crushers because I just like so long as
they're tied to these big batteries
hopefully at least one of them will be
able to run like at a time but honestly
who knows then another manual generator
I suppose all right bring it out of the
Berzin and why not let's bring someone
else
ah good Virgil a physician we could use
that come on in here it's bad it's it's
bad in here it's it's pretty damn bad
it's it's real bad it's it's like real
bad but we got this so you guys believe
in me out there - I know you do I know
you really do I know yeah 100% think
that I'm definitely confident and
capable as a leader to lead these people
into life you know the hard challenge of
staying alive Ness so to build the algae
conversion you need to be able to have
the just the bio distill the bio
distiller needs power and then a place
to shunt all of the contaminated water
and that's it
that's literally all it is so if the bio
distiller is say right outside the door
then we could possibly build or maybe if
the bio distiller is right here and then
I could destroy those things
maybe the bio distiller is here I don't
know okay
so what I'm gonna do is for the storage
sake the storage is right outside this
door and that's where the slime is gonna
go eventually we'll go get this guy who
produces all the slime we want but right
now we're just gonna worry about
harvesting it then from there we're
gonna make sure that they can get to
this area here and then we're gonna
build okay once we do this ties these
things goddammit Oh will they stop
hitting that one battery we got to
connect this bad boy here maybe I should
have signed ok that's Lenny whoa you max
Josie who else is stressed your vet all
live probably meep I know you're
stressed oh man oh my guys oh man but
that means there's not enough like
there's not enough for everybody who see
I don't know how these work
I just don't know okay it looks like
powers back up that's nice
I go for a Josie you power up the whole
shebang don't you oh you need okay we're
making mush bars we're making nothing
but mush bars cuz we need food we need
lots of food if there's one thing I do
its provide from my foodies so they're
gonna get food okay this is done so now
we can make the the converter the bio
distiller which then can just pump it
can just palm if I destroy this and then
obviously these aren't doing [ __ ] so I
mean they're providing oxygen and then
there's no oxygen in here but they don't
really Nick go in there for very long
and the bio distiller can just dump
water straight down the bottom and then
shebang Shaboom we got a steady supply
of algae right that's how it works right
that's how it works that's all I know so
we're just gonna pump these straight
down that's all it's gonna be oh look at
all mohei
oh hell yeah you getting less stress
buddy boo hey Gus how you feeling woo
Gus is at 94 oh that's ma that's better
alright thanks so then we got the bio
distillers going up there
do they need power I don't think they
need power because they're oh they do
need power okay so they're gonna need
their own individual power source so
we'll just have manual generator here
and one big battery there and that goes
across I'm gonna eventually will do more
do their thing then we'll have algae
finally have algae so this is only
literally only for slime this is only
for salon that's the only thing it's for
that's the only thing it will be for and
that's all we're gonna use that for oh
look at that they're getting massages
they're getting massages
oh good for them good for them good for
them oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh hell
yeah oh hell yeah okay so that means I'm
gonna fill this one because these are
all getting a little bonus from the
extra light because they're like
directly under a light source so that's
kind of good
these are gonna get built soon okay
stress vomiting I know I know I know I
know I know I know I'm well aware of
this I am aware okay so I need to what I
need to do though Lenny's dead
died of starvation I'm really sad we
lost one
oh man max you just got a massage you're
in morning I give it oh no no max broke
something and then immediately got a
massage I get it okay these have got to
be like these got to be high priority we
just need we need mush like that's all
we need
we just need the mush so anyway now that
we got that out of the way you can start
harvesting this slime I don't know if
these are gonna produce contaminated
oxygen while they're doing it I'm
assuming they are but eventually we will
need to we'll need to seal it off and
Lenny is just right there on the ground
we're almost out of water here
[Music]
I bet he's not gonna be the last
he's not gonna be the last to die is he
hot dama I thought I could save him I
yelled at Lenny so much feel bad poor
Lenny but at least things are falling
into place I suppose I may not seem like
it but things are falling into place
people are still mad people are still
stressed I know everyone everyone's
stressed I'm well aware oh but I think
I'm gonna end this episode here cuz what
else can I do so thank you everybody so
much for watching this is I'm trying my
best here I'm trying to salvage this
we're getting there but it's a slow
process it's a slow process but we are
getting there so thank you everybody so
much for watching as always I will see
you in the next bye bye
[Music]